the commonwealth of virginia republican
governor glenn younkin he continues to
be stonewalled by the state's far left
machine as he stands up to the failing
biden agenda here to explain more
virginia governor glenn younken is with
us
first i want to applaud you
we have laws on the books 18 ufc 1507
that prohibits people from intimidating
and harassing
judges and a lot of supreme court
justices now live in the commonwealth
northern virginia and you have been
urging the democrats in
the commonwealth to support you to
protect them and they're not going along
why not
well sean first thanks for having me and
virginians elected me last november to
go to work and we went to work right on
day one
we've had we've had an incredibly strong
legislative session getting
parents reestablished to make decisions
about masks on their children and with
explicit materials in schools to get
them out of their kids curriculum and we
just signed a budget today that lowered
taxes by 4 billion dollars and funds 400
million dollars into law enforcement and
oh by the way we'll have the largest
education budget in the history of
virginia and we're promoting school
choice with tax credits and lab schools
so we've had a great first five months
but i am really frustrated that the
amendment that i sent down to mimic to
copy the federal statute that u.s
attorney general garland will not
enforce to keep our justices safe people
should not be allowed to pick it and
protest in front of our u.s supreme
court justices and try to influence them
and that's exactly what that law says
it's punishable with up to a year in
prison i want that law in virginia i
couldn't get it most recently but i'm
going to keep trying and we're going to
get that governor justice is safe
we saw
we were able to stop
an assassination plot against justice
kavanaugh we now know the doxing of
every justice has taken place in the
case of amy coney barrett these people
are giving out the exact school where
her children go they're telling people
what church she goes to and when she
goes to church that to me is beyond
intimidation and harassment it is a
direct threat to their safety and of
course a threat to the judiciary at
large
you can't get democrats to support that
we can't get democrats to support that
and i'll tell you sean we're doing
everything we can with our state police
and with local law enforcement and
governor hogan and i watched what
happened with that with that
assassination attempt on justice
kavanaugh and have gone to work again to
to implore us attorney general garland
to enforce the law but we've got
ample resources parked right outside of
our justices homes to make sure that
they're safe i speak to them frequently
i i'm 100 focused on keeping them safe
and this is paramount in our
administration and without the help from
democrats in the in the senate in the
house and virginia we can still do
so much to keep our justices safe but
i'm going to send that bill back down
and virginia will at one point
incorporating its code these exact same
laws
so joe biden will address the country
tomorrow two o'clock eastern time so
he's scheduled uh to talk about gas
prices
i'm sure we'll talk about once again
tapping the
strategic
petroleum reserves and maybe eliminate
the national gas tax
i believe for him it would be a gimmick
because i think the minute the election
is over they'll institute the tax again
regardless
of the price of gasoline but you're
doing it in a way to really help the
people of virginia you don't have an
election coming up but people now paying
five six dollars a gallon for gasoline
add that to 41 a 41-year high of
inflation
everything we buy in every store we go
to is costing us a fortune and the
average family cannot afford this
economy of joe biden
will it work
sean they can't everywhere i go all i
hear is governor help us inflation is
the silent thief stealing our
hard-earned money that's why i'm so
proud of this budget we signed today a
four billion dollar tax cut for
virginians four times larger than any
tax cut ever voted for in virginia and
we're gonna see this immediately impact
virginians with with eleven hundred
dollars of tax cuts for the typical
virginia family in year one that doesn't
come close to overcoming this biden
economy which is just driving inflation
beyond virginians and americans
capabilities to pay for it but as a but
as a governor that was sent here to get
things done
when we can lower taxes and we can fund
law enforcement and we can in fact
deliver new jobs with companies like
boeing and raytheon and lego moving to
virginia to put virginians who want to
work hard in these great jobs we've had
a great first five months and i am proud
of what we've done but we've got a lot
more to do and i got to give you credit
too you did restore school choice in the
commonwealth of virginia well done uh
governor glenn young thank you for being
with us hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else